how are you wanda i'm doing quite well
how are you conan i'm okay i think i
speak for all of us when i say
hold up with family uh during quarantine
it can be great and then there's a whole
other side of that coin how are you
doing
i i you know what um i'm afraid to
complain
yeah that's that's how i am you know
it's like oh no i'm good
yeah i'm good yeah you see the rest of
the stuff that's going on i'm like
you know what i'm pretty good but um
yeah it's i know exactly what you mean
about being
held up with family and yeah doing the
online
studies you know school it's yeah well
who's like for example who does the
cooking in this situation
in in your house who does the cooking
well i like to cook
i like to cook um so i i do most of the
cooking
um but it's been uh you know like i said
not gonna complain but i haven't had an
oven
since uh like two weeks before
thanksgiving
did your oven blow up or something what
happened just die
i don't know what happened you know
usually when i go away
for a while and i come back something's
broken
something's not working right anymore
right this time they
they killed the oven so i think
it's hard to get you know what it's i'm
thinking about it it's hard to kill an
oven it really is
hey i i don't know how she did it but
uh alex broke a volvo
you know how hard it is
alex is your wife she broke a volvo yeah
i'm not
i shouldn't say she did it well all i
know is my car was fine
and then she drove it i came back
it was it was in the shop for like two
weeks
[Laughter]
wait so you don't have an oven how do
you cook if you don't have an oven you
said you haven't had an oven in months
what do you do
everything is has been going on the
grill anything that needs to go
on the in the oven i gotta cook it on
the grill which is real fun when it's
you standing in snow
yeah that's right because you're you're
on the east coast now so
man uh grilling out in the snow
is not it's not a joy no and i i know
my neighbors are probably like man you
know i i knew black people like barbecue
but
she is taking it to the next event
this fish is always on
this is not helping with the stereotype
that's the problem yeah
um now wait a minute are you doing uh
shopping yourself
or you do instacart like a lot of people
like to get on the phone and do that
instacart
uh during uh a pandemic or do you like
to go yourself
i like to go myself but i'm not you know
i don't go like
uh often i make a quick list i do a huge
you know shop and i do the face mask and
the face shield
and all but uh you know i was i was in
uh whole foods you know um
spending my kids college fun and um
you gotta do that i don't know why trust
me
it's incred you go to whole foods and
you look at like a fat a bag of grapes
and you think i need to call my
accountant first
it's incredible yeah so yeah but anyway
so you're at whole foods
right and i'm doing my shopping at first
you know i'm i guess not really paying
attention but i'm like
wow that's like got a lot of young black
people in here
shopping at whole foods we coming up
this is nice and i realized like oh no
they're shopping
for other people you know like oh
they're the instacart shoppers right
they're doing yeah they're actually
going to shopping and then i was like
damn dad you know all these young people
putting them putting themselves at risk
doing the shopping and they gotta go
home to their parents or other family
members who you know
like i said it's like really putting us
at risk but hey white people enjoy your
chilean sea bass
yeah that's uh that's not right that's
not right yeah
uh well what about are your kids
are your kids i'm thinking nope i have
not eaten chilean sea bass for a while
so i have no guilt there